il est rare qu'un procès mobilise autant
350 personnes hier devant le tribunal de
chalon sur saône pour rendre hommage à
fugee et de nombreux messages sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'auteur présumé des faits a reconnu à
la barre avoir brûlé le chien qui est
décédé quelques jours plus tard mais
elle ne s'attendait pas à de telles
répercussions
elle est quand même très déstabilisés
par l'ampleur par la médiatisation qui a
été donnée sur le plan local et national
est ce dossier que ça crée l'émotion
c'est parfaitement l'entendre mais on
aura rarement vu ça dans les annales
judiciaires le tribunal s'est penché sur
le profil psychologique et de cette
femme de 38 ans qui n'avait jusque là
pas de casier judiciaire
elle vit dans un climat social difficile
s'est vu retirer la garde de ses deux
enfants est suivi par un psychologue
après une tentative de suicide l'année
dernière le procureur a requis à son
encontre 18 mois de prison dont neuf
mois ferme
on a eu des réquisitions qui ont été
bien amener qui ont bien expliqué parce
que bon ella ella ella a mené son
réquisitoire elle est arrivée au lieu du
problème c'est la barbarie de l'apd la
volonté de tuer mais en faisant souffrir
le boss c'est ça qui est gravement
blessé l'afer est mise en délibéré la
décision du tribunal sera rendue lundi
prochain